melissa is with us Melissa in Kansas
City how are you Melissa I'm doing well
how are you today Dave better than I
deserve merry Christmas to you how can I
help I am calling today because my
husband and I are trying to decide if he
should leave his job without having
another one lined up due to the toxic
work environment that he is currently in
we have he had some stock options that
were filibuster this year that we were
able to cash out so we have some extra
cash right now
we were planning on putting down on the
house because around baby steps 4 5 & 6
how much do you have in your emergency
fund 30,000 and how much is in this
stock we have 45,000 to put down on the
house
what does he make a year this sure was
about a hundred okay what does he do for
a living
he is a financial reporter or CPA oh
okay how hard is it going to be to him
for him to replace this job you know
he's had some interviews he's actually
we've been kind of thinking about this
for over a year and nothing has you know
the right position hasn't come up yet
and he's he's 41 years old he's kind of
looking for
he doesn't want just another job he
wants something that he's passionate
about that's a good place a good
environment you know he doesn't want to
jump from one bad thing to another you
know just to pay the bills and and so
you know we're we're really trying to
Zone in on that and to make sure it's
the right move but you know it's just
been a tough week he came home twice and
asked us in his frustration if he could
quit and so I feel bad I I stay home
full-time with our children
Andrew Brad
because it's wearing on him and I know
she's carrying a lot of that pressure
also to to provide for our family yeah
yeah that's big-boy stuff um so what is
the nature of the toxicity and boss is a
bully
you can known to yell and swear at
people and really just rides people hard
doesn't appreciate them and it you've
been there for two and a half years and
after about a year and a half he was
that might he was ready to move on
because it was already starting to where
he he had financial incentives this day
and through this fall and so we we were
able to he was able to hold on that long
and as he confronted anyone in the
organization about this you know it's a
small start-up company and the boss
owned the place
no he does not but even the even the
management team they pretty much just
ignore this guy and let him do what he
want one other guy lose what they're
getting ready to lose talent because of
it because they're horrible leaders and
so um you know here's the thing if
you're going to quit you know what you
have no job yeah so you know what I do I
would walk in there and start messing
with these people you know I go sit down
with the owner of the company and go
listen um I'm on the verge of putting in
my notice because of this abuse and if
you want to continue to endorse this
abuse you just need to let me know and
I'll be giving you my notice in the next
few months
this is absolutely out of control and
you guys you know the leadership just
sucks you say it however you want to say
it but give them a shot at turning it
around sit you might get the guy fired
and then you can stay until you want to
leave meantime I'm going to turn up the
heat I'm not going to just quit and walk
out with my tail between my legs I mean
going there and impact the thing what's
the worst case scenario they're firing
oh darn
he was gonna quit anyway try it you guys
would be so rich so fast and be able to
do so much not only for yourselves and
for your family but for others